BILL BILLENSTEIN: Thank you
all very much for joining us
in the Big Lebowski today for
another guest chef's Google
LAX.
I'm Chef Bill Billenstein.
Today we are very excited
to have Chef Yuichi
Natori from CHAYA Venice.
Chef Natori-san started his
career many years ago in Japan,
at the Tsuji Culinary
Institute in Osaka,
traveled all around
the globe learning
many, many different
tricks and techniques.
He has been the chef at CHAYA
Venice for approximately
the last 23 years.
So today, he's going to make
some great favorites of his.
We've got the
lobster enchiladas.
We've got the croissant
bread pudding.
And a little bit of codfish
that--I don't know if you guys
can smell that, but I'm very,
very excited about that.
So please welcome
Chef Natori-san.
YUICHI NATORI: All
right, nice to meet you.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, I've been here 20 years.
So my cooking's getting better,
but my English is not so good.
A little bit, so--
SARA BALDONI: But the language
of love is food, right?
I'm Sara.
I do marketing for
CHAYA restaurant.
So I'm not really, you know,
in the kitchen nearly as much
as I'd like to be.
But I can talk about
everything else.
So you want to start with
the lobster enchiladas?
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah.
We starting the
lobster enchiladas.
So this is a lobster tail.
And its cut in like
a one-inch square.
And with tomato and cilantro,
jalapeno, and onion.
Cut in like so pico
de gallo salsa.
But not mix it up.
So onion and tomato.
And the tortilla, so.
SARA BALDONI: Are they
corn tortillas, Chef?
YUICHI NATORI:
No, this is flour.
SARA BALDONI: Oh.
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah.
This good for flour.
Not corn.
Much better.
SARA BALDONI: Corn's not good?
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah.
Because corn kill the
flavor of the lobster.
So yeah, flower is much better.
So we're going to start cooking.
OK.
SARA BALDONI: The
lobster enchiladas
are a huge favorite
at CHAYA Venice.
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah, it's
ten years more in the--
SARA BALDONI: Maine lobster?
It is Maine lobster, correct?
YUICHI NATORI: This one
is a Pacific lobster.
But we using a
Maine lobster, so.
So oil, put in the pan.
SARA BALDONI: During the summer,
we actually did a fun lobster
promotion on Sundays, where
it was a half-priced lobster
every Sunday.
That was all fresh
Maine lobster, flown in.
YUICHI NATORI: I'm putting
the salt and pepper
on the lobster-- just lobster.
SARA BALDONI: Little
olive oil, Chef?
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah.
Little olive oil in the pan.
And we cook the lobster
first, so cook it through.
SARA BALDONI: How do
you know when it's done?
YUICHI NATORI: Color
change to white.
OK.
SARA BALDONI: Can
you guys smell that?
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah.
SARA BALDONI: Delicious.
YUICHI NATORI: So lobster--
yeah, it's cooked through.
So put in the onion
and the tomato.
But onion and tomato, put
in here so not cook more.
Just a little bit.
SARA BALDONI: Just a little.
Just to incorporate the flavors.
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah.
Yeah, it's this way.
Then going to make a sauce.
It's cream, butter,
mixed up, soak.
SARA BALDONI: It's
cream and butter?
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah.
And salt and pepper,
it's already inside, so.
This is a cilantro pesto.
So this already make
it so my restaurant.
But it's shallots, garlic,
cilantro, Italian parsley,
and olive oil, salt and
pepper, and mix a blender.
SARA BALDONI: That's so easy.
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah, so easy.
SARA BALDONI: Cilantro,
olive oil, salt and pepper--
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah, it's
on the recipe, right?
So just put it in a
blender and mix it.
SARA BALDONI: Emulsify.
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah.
And wait now, heat it up.
And the way heat it up,
so put in there and mix.
It's a cilantro cream sauce.
SARA BALDONI: That green color
just shines through, too.
YUICHI NATORI: And
heat it up pan.
SARA BALDONI: Has anyone
tried the lobster enchiladas
at CHAYA Venice?
They're definitely
one of the favorites.
And what I was saying
earlier, so there's
three different CHAYAs in
LA and one in San Francisco.
And each one kind of has
its own signature items.
This is one of the signature
items at Venice, definitely.
I think even if we tried
to take it off the menu,
there might be
pitchforks outside.
YUICHI NATORI:
Everybody upset, no?
SARA BALDONI: Everyone loves it.
So just heat up the
tortilla just a little?
YUICHI NATORI: Tortilla, yeah.
No oil, it's fine.
OK.
It's done.
So the lobster, the
center of the tortilla.
And rolled up.
Then sauce on top.
SARA BALDONI: You make
it look so easy, Chef.
You make it look so simple.
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah.
We put in there.
So tomato-- usually,
tomato on the top.
And so micro cilantro.
SARA BALDONI: Little micro
cilantro for garnish.
YUICHI NATORI: Garnish
on top of [INAUDIBLE].
SARA BALDONI: Beautiful.
That took three minutes.
[APPLAUSE]
SARA BALDONI: So easy.
YUICHI NATORI: Thank you.
And the next, so.
SARA BALDONI: You guys are
going to get to taste everything
that we make as well.
So get excited.
YUICHI NATORI: This is
the black cod from Alaska.
Yeah.
SARA BALDONI: It's
an Alaskan black cod.
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah.
We marinate it in a
sake, soy sauce, mirin.
And so--
SARA BALDONI: Just a mixture
of sake, soy, and mirin.
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah.
And marinate it in one night.
SARA BALDONI: Just one night?
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah, one night.
So more than one day, it's a
little bit salty, the fish.
SARA BALDONI: What's your
favorite kind of sake
to cook with?
YUICHI NATORI: Huh?
The cheapest.
SARA BALDONI: The cheapest one?
YUICHI NATORI:
Yeah, for cooking.
Drinking is a good one.
But using to cook
is the cheapest.
Not different flavor.
SARA BALDONI: Good to know.
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah.
Good one, sake,
you have to drink.
SARA BALDONI: You have
to drink that one.
YUICHI NATORI: So is one night,
so marinate the black cod.
So it's put in the
oven, 400 degrees oven.
Yeah.
About ten minutes.
SARA BALDONI: That's it?
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah.
It'll make the color,
it's a little bit--
SARA BALDONI: It
browns a little bit?
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah,
it browns a little bit.
It's done, so you--
SARA BALDONI: Oh, so
that's how you know.
When the outside kind
of browns a little bit.
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah.
SARA BALDONI: So you
just put it in the oven.
Do you put it in the oven
in the pan-- in the skillet?
YUICHI NATORI: No, no.
Just the oven's fine.
But no oven here, so that's
why it's already cooking.
SARA BALDONI: So
imagine that part.
That was already pre-done.
YUICHI NATORI: It's a fish.
AUDIENCE: So it's 400?
That's
YUICHI NATORI:
Yeah, 400 degrees.
SARA BALDONI: It's 400
degrees for about ten minutes.
YUICHI NATORI: About ten minutes
to fifteen minutes, yeah.
And this is hijiki.
You know hijiki?
SARA BALDONI: Hijiki seaweed?
YUICHI NATORI: Seaweed.
Yeah, you can get from
a Japanese market.
SARA BALDONI: Like a Mitsuwa?
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah, Mitsuwa
on Venice and Centinela.
Or I think that
Whole Foods has it.
SARA BALDONI: I think there's--
you know that section of Whole
Foods where there's all the--
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah, it's dry.
But it's in the dry.
SARA BALDONI: So it's
already prepared like this?
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah,
already prepared.
But it's in the dry.
So dry hijiki, put in
warm water is 15 minutes.
SARA BALDONI: And it
absorbs all of the water.
And then it's ready to eat.
YUICHI NATORI: So is clean
up the water and add them.
So cook it with the
carrots and onion.
And the sake, soy sauce, mirin.
Yeah.
The recipe says that, so.
Until to no watery, so that--
SARA BALDONI: So you kind
of saute it together?
Yeah?
And evaporate all
the water and then it
absorbs all the
onion and the carrot?
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah,
and the [INAUDIBLE].
SARA BALDONI: I'm learning
with you guys, this is great.
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah,
I put it in here
so if you want to taste
it, so you can taste it.
And it's put in there,
so mix up brown rice.
And cook the brown
rice so it's good.
SARA BALDONI: It's delicious.
The hijiki brown
rice is wonderful.
This dish is one of
my ultimate favorites.
This is really a CHAYA staple.
So all four CHAYA locations
actually offer this.
There's a couple items that will
be offered at every location,
like the miso glazed back
cod, our chicken Dijon which
is in a mustard Dijon sauce.
Our tuna tartar--
actually, Chef Tachibe, who
was going to be here--
little side note,
we are opening up
our next location
in the international
terminal, actually, at LAX.
They've done a huge project
over there and it's beautiful.
So we're opening up a little
CHAYA sushi over there.
It's a sushi concept.
And so they're doing
some opening stuff.
It's going to be opening
in the next couple weeks
here, which is very exciting.
But Chef Tachibe, who is
our corporate executive chef
for all of the
CHAYA restaurants,
his knife and chef
coat are actually
in the Smithsonian
Museum in New York
City for inventing tuna tartar.
Little known fact, but
a very, very big one.
So it's something we're
very excited about.
Then I make a fried rice.
Hijiki brown rice fried rice.
I saw at Trader Joe's.
It's the same thing.
SARA BALDONI: They have the
same one at Trader Joe's.
So you guys can skip
all of these steps.
YUICHI NATORI: If you want to--
SARA BALDONI: It won't
taste nearly as good.
They do.
I have seen that,
actually, at Trader Joe's.
YUICHI NATORI: Maybe I
think they stole it, so.
SARA BALDONI: They
stole it from CHAYA.
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah,
ingredients, I saw, the same.
SARA BALDONI: It's
pretty much the same.
Skip a step.
Don't even have
to go to Mitsuwa.
Yeah.
Do you guys have any
questions so far?
AUDIENCE: Is black
cod easy to find?
SARA BALDONI: Is black
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah,
a little bit harder.
But maybe you can go
to Santa Monica fish.
They have it, yeah.
SARA BALDONI: It's one
of my favorite fishes.
It just absorbs all of the
flavor of the marinade.
And it's just so
flaky and delicious.
I hope you guys enjoy it.
YUICHI NATORI: And
this is eel sauce.
SARA BALDONI: Eel sauce?
So it's unagi sauce, that
comes on a lot of the sushis.
A little sweet?
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah, you can
get it from-- yeah, sweet.
Also, you can get at
Japanese market, yeah.
It's already fried, so--
SARA BALDONI: That's it?
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah, it's fried.
SARA BALDONI: Slightly fried.
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah.
Fried rice.
Then the fish.
And the sauteed
shiitake mushroom.
Put it in the garnish.
And the asparagus, steamed.
SARA BALDONI: So was there
any sauteing or anything
to be done to the fish, or
is it all baked previously?
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah, baked.
So now put in the sauce and
then just a little bit chives.
And then--
SARA BALDONI: Oh, chives.
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah, micro
[INAUDIBLE], that's all.
This is a black--
SARA BALDONI: It's so pretty.
YUICHI NATORI: Thank you.
SARA BALDONI: So
Chef Natori-san, you
have been at CHAYA
Venice for 23 years now?
YUICHI NATORI: 20.
20 years.
SARA BALDONI: 20 years.
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah.
SARA BALDONI: Very nice.
CHAYA Venice opened
23 years ago.
The original CHAYA actually
opened in Beverly Hills.
I don't know if-- have
you guys been to that one,
right off Robertson?
Yeah?
That one just celebrated
30 years in Los Angeles.
So we had a huge party.
We had a huge
festival, nonetheless.
It was really exciting.
You went.
You brought your family.
YUICHI NATORI: Because
I already make it there.
No over here, so that's why.
This is very easy.
So just recipe.
Just cut with the
finger in the croissant
and then make a-- mix in cream.
SARA BALDONI: That's it?
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah, that's it.
Doing this one.
So becoming this.
SARA BALDONI: So you
just kind of break up--
tear up the croissant,
you add your chocolate,
your pudding cream--
now, is pudding cream--
what makes pudding
cream different from--
YUICHI NATORI: So
make a pudding cream.
Yeah, pudding cream.
SARA BALDONI: So pudding
cream is just the egg yolk,
the granulated sugar, and the
manufactured cream all mixed
together.
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah.
And so put in the pan with--
SARA BALDONI: With the vanilla?
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah,
croissant and pudding cream.
SARA BALDONI: And
then you just bake it?
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah.
Just put in the oven.
Bake in this minutes.
SARA BALDONI: 35
minutes at 340 degrees.
YUICHI NATORI: 35
SARA BALDONI: Now,
there's actually a face.
There's something that we like
to call the CHAYA chocolate
croissant bread pudding face,
because-- have any of you
had it, the bread
pudding at CHAYA?
Yeah?
Is it good?
Right?
I'm thinking about
starting a hashtag for it,
because every time
I've introduced
any of my friends or family
members to this bread pudding,
they all make the same face.
It's something similar to, oh
my God, which is a good thing.
It really has become a staple
over the past 30 years, nearly.
And it's a lot of fun.
And apparently, it's
super simple to make.
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah.
Don't forget--
SARA BALDONI: So I'm
a little bit worried.
YUICHI NATORI: --chocolate is--
SARA BALDONI: The
chocolate is essential.
YUICHI NATORI: --last one.
SARA BALDONI: It's
the secret ingredient?
And that goes last?
YUICHI NATORI: No,
not put it in yet.
So before oven, so chocolate.
SARA BALDONI: OK, before.
And then it all bakes together?
YUICHI NATORI: After
bake together, then
chocolate put on
the top and the--
SARA BALDONI: On top?
YUICHI NATORI: So
melting like this.
SARA BALDONI: Oh,
so you add it right
when you take it out of
the oven, when it's warm.
We have a question?
AUDIENCE: How do you
create [INAUDIBLE]?
SARA BALDONI: Yeah,
is manufactured cream
the same as kind
of a heavy cream,
or a heavy whipping cream?
YUICHI NATORI:
Yeah, heavy cream.
SARA BALDONI: Exactly.
Good question.
So then?
YUICHI NATORI: You can put
in some ice cream on top.
YUICHI NATORI:
And it melts down.
You know.
I'm going to start using
that dulce de leche ice
cream on top of that.
SARA BALDONI: Dulce de leche?
YUICHI NATORI: Mm.
SARA BALDONI: Really good.
So you kind of just put it in
a ramekin or a little skillet,
depending on what
you want to do.
YUICHI NATORI: Anything, yeah.
SARA BALDONI: It's so simple.
I don't think I
could do it, though.
YUICHI NATORI: Well,
come our restaurant.
SARA BALDONI: Top it with
a little powdered sugar.
And that's it.
YUICHI NATORI: That's it.
SARA BALDONI: And
that's everything.
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah.
SARA BALDONI: Wow.
[APPLAUSE]
That's so fun.
Does anyone have any questions?
Ooh, another question.
AUDIENCE: If we don't
have a convection oven,
does that change the time
that it takes to bake?
SARA BALDONI: Like a convection
versus a regular oven?
YUICHI NATORI: Regular
oven is fine, yeah.
SARA BALDONI: Will
it affect the time?
Do you have to do it a little
longer without a convection?
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah,
just check it up,
you know, after 30 minutes.
Check it up so it's
down or not down.
In the enchiladas,
[INAUDIBLE] Parmesan cheese?
SARA BALDONI: Well, there
was no Parmesan cheese
in the enchilada, no.
The only cheese was
in the cream sauce.
YUICHI NATORI: Oh, sorry.
Put in the-- so, yeah, cream.
I forget, so, yeah.
Put Parmesan cheese in there.
SARA BALDONI: In the sauce.
YUICHI NATORI: In the sauce.
AUDIENCE: If we can't find
black cod, is there another fish
that--
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah, using cod.
Cod.
SARA BALDONI: So cod will
have the same texture and--
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah.
Put in and marinate it.
So it tastes like same, so.
Or try salmon.
Yeah, salmon is
also so tastes good.
SARA BALDONI: With
the same marinade?
YUICHI NATORI:
Yeah, same marinade.
SARA BALDONI: Good replacement.
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah.
In Japan, so salmon
use in there.
So just marinate it, yeah.
SARA BALDONI: Cool.
YUICHI NATORI: Now, so--
SARA BALDONI: Yeah, so
now we'll go get you guys
some food, the moment
you've all been waiting for.
Tachibe is the original
corporate chef as well,
so he's been with us for 30
years, since brasserie opened.
Yeah.
It's a big family.
Enchiladas.
AUDIENCE: So I guess you
guys aren't open for lunch?
SARA BALDONI: We are
open for lunch, actually.
CHAYA Venice is
definitely open for lunch.
We've got some help back there.
So we figured we could stop
by for a couple minutes.
Yeah, you think the kitchen will
be OK without you, Natori-san?
YUICHI NATORI: I think so.
SARA BALDONI: Fingers crossed.
YUICHI NATORI: Yeah, it's OK.
So just opened up an hour or so.
SARA BALDONI: It just opened
up, yeah-- oh yeah, at 11:30.
YUICHI NATORI: Sauce pan.
SARA BALDONI: Oh, yeah.
One thing that's really
exciting that we're doing,
actually, at Brasserie,
is in celebration
of our 30th anniversary,
I said we had a big party.
We had a huge festival.
We had fire dancers.
We had taiko drummers.
We had two live bands.
It was ridiculous.
All you can eat,
all you can drink.
It was a lot of fun.
But we're also bringing
over our original CHAYA.
Now, CHAYA is a family owned,
operated, run business.
And it goes back
nearly 400 years.
It started in Japan,
the first one.
Hikage-chaya is
still in operation.
And our chef from that
location is actually
going to be joining us.
We're flying him out for a
special chef collaboration
dinner, which is
really, really cool.
He's a Michelin star chef for
the Hikage-chaya in Japan.
And he's coming over
for two nights only,
on October 18th and 19th,
which is really cool.
It's a kaiseki style.
I don't know if--is anyone
familiar with kaiseki style?
It's very traditional kind
of Japanese small plates--
really, really kind
of hyper seasonal.
It was really
difficult, because we
kept trying to get a menu for
what we were going to serve.
And he was like, you
know, it's two months away
and we don't know
what's seasonal.
Everything is so local,
so seasonal over in Japan.
We talk about farm
to table here,
but it's a whole different
spectrum over there.
So it's like a multi-course,
very kind of small plates,
everything-- there's so
much care that goes into it.
So it's a lot of fun.
Look at this.
Oh my god.
So yeah, we're
going to be having
a chef collaboration
with Chef Tachibe
and Chef Kazuka-san from
Japan October 18 and 19,
which is incredible.
It's very limited.
So I believe it's going
to be seven courses.
Wine and sake pairings
are also available.
Only 20 seatings per timeframe.
So it's only about 160 people
total throughout the two
nights.
It's going to be an
incredible evening.
There is enough
food for everyone.
Wow.